Викидати батарейки в смітник не можна - вони забруднюють довкілля токсичними речовинами.
Цьому дітей вчать в українських школах і мотивують їх збирати батарейки.
Школярі це роблять завзято, з упевненістю, що рятують світ.
Але дитяча впевненість закінчується
на спеціалізованому комунальному підприємстві "Київкомунсервіс",
якезбирає від бюджетних установ і населення використані батарейки.
Ось контейнери для збору відпрацьованих батарейок
Таких комунальних боксів у Києві близько ста тридцяти.
І все, що тутназбиралося за останні п’ять років, так і не утилізували.
За період збору батарейок накопичено вже близько 50 тонн.
Вони знаходяться на складі для тимчасового зберігання,
оскільки в Україні немає потужності для їх утилізації.
За висновками міністерства екології,в Україні взагалінемає жодного підприємства
з сучасними технологіями повного циклу переробки відпрацьованих хімічних джерел струму.
Є лише кілька заводів, які останні п’ять років час від часу приймали батарейки
і робили часткову утилізацію.
Туди за власний кошт здавали зібрані від клієнтів батарейки великі торговельні мережі.
На заправкахKLO, приміром, кожен квартал накопичується від трьох до шести тонн батарейок.
Наразі не існує чіткого законодавчого акту, який би регулював,
підказував, як проходитьутилізація, до яких служб потрібно звертатися.
На жаль, вибирати не було  з чого.
Був єдиний завод в Україні"Аргентум", на який ми відправляли ці батарейки. Наразі він не працює.
Попри це, великі торговельні мережі та комунальні підприємства
не хочуть припиняти збирати батарейки.
Адже завозиться їх в Україну щороку від трьох до десяти тисяч тонн, здають лише 1%.
Решта опиняється на сміттєзвалищі і отруює довкілля.
В "Київкомунсервісі" думають про утилізацію накопичених батарейок на заводі у Польщі.
Хоча це буде дуже непросто.
Нам треба все правильно підготувати, все правильно посортувати,все правильно скласти.
Відповідно до законодавства тієї країни,всіх норм і вимог.
В Україні, за даними міністерства екології, є приблизно 300 складів з небезпечними відходами.
Майже усі вони не в кращому технічному стані.
Тож ніхто не гарантує, що відпрацьовані джерела струму не зіпсувалися аж так,
що їх неможливо перевозити.
Люди поступово втрачають мотивацію здавати батарейки.
Оскільки немає повноцінної утилізації, забруднюється довкілля.
І це все збирання …в иходить, що це обман по факту.
Громадська мережа"Батарейки, здавайтеся!"
накопичила на складах у Києві і Дніпрі вже 50 тонн.
Їх зберігають за гроші небайдужих українців.
Активісти хочуть відвезти зібрані батарейки в Європу і ведуть перемовини з німецьким заводом.
Розумно утилізувати батарейки Україна зобов'язана відповідно до Угоди про Асоціацію з ЄС.
Уряд вже розробив Національну стратегію поводження з небезпечними відходами
і чекає на ухвалення Верховною Радою відповідних законів.
Утім, перших результатів очікують не раніше, ніж через 3-5 років.